.
DEMOCRATS ALWAYS GIVE THEMSELVES
A FREE PASS.
WE'LL HAVE MORE ON THIS IN PART
TWO OF MY MONOLOGUE STATE.
BUT FIRST THE GOVERNOR OF
FLORIDA, RON DESANTIS, IS WITH
US.
I KNOW YOU HAVEN'T SLEPT IN THE
LAST 72 HOURS OR LONGER, BEEN
GOING AROUND THE STATE.
$100 BILLION NOW ESTIMATED IN
DAMAGE.
DAWNING THAT'S ACCURATE?
WE LOST, I THINK, THE LAST COUNT
IS 68 PEOPLE DIED IN THE STORM.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
ACCURATE, BUT THE LIVES LOST ARE
SIGNIFICANT, BECAUSE THAT'S
SOMETHING WE CAN'T BUILD BACK.
THOSE LOSSES ARE TOUGH.
THERE'S PROPERTY DAMAGE.
THERE'S A SPIRIT OUT THERE,
PARTICULARLY THE PEOPLE OF
SOUTHWEST FLORIDA, THEY'RE READY
TO BOUNCE BACK.
THEY NEED SOME HELP.
WE'RE DOWN THERE DOING IT, BUT
THEY HAVE A LOT OF GRIT AND
DETERMINATION.
I ACTUALLY WAS JUST IN ONE OF
THE SHELTERS.
I'M MEETING WITH WOMEN WHO ARE
85-90 YEARS OLD WHO SURVIVED
BEING IN SOME OF THE ISLANDS,
AND THEY'RE TELLING THEIR
STORIES, BASICALLY THANKING GOD,
BUT SO THANKFUL FOR ALL THE
OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT OF
EVERYBODY HELPING OUR STATE.
SO I JUST THINK THOSE WHO HAVE
EITHER DONATED TO
FLORIDADISASTERFUND.ORG, JUST
KNOW THE PEOPLE IMPACTED BY
THIS, WHO LOST EVERYTHING, THEY
ARE TRULY GRATEFUL FOR THE
OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT.
>> Sean: GOVERNOR, THEY'RE
SAYING THAT SANIBEL ISLAND MAY
BE UNINHABITABLE.
I KNOW FORT MYERS WELL.
I KNOW NAPLES WELL.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THE AMOUNT OF
DAMAGE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
IT WAS A DIRECT HIT.
IT DECIMATED SOME OF THESE
AREAS.
AS OF NOW, WHERE DO YOU SEE THIS
GOING IN THE FUTURE?
DO YOU BELIEVE EVERYBODY IN
SANIBEL, FOR EXAMPLE, WILL HAVE
TO COME OFF THE ISLAND?
>> WELL, WE'RE TRYING TO AVOID
THAT.
I JUST ANNOUNCED TODAY THAT MY
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION WE
JUST PUT OUT BIDS FOR A
TEMPORARY BRIDGE TO LINK THE
ISLAND BACK TO THE MAINLAND.
THERE'S A CAUSEWAY THAT HAD DONE
THAT.
IT GOT SEVERED IN THREE
DIFFERENT PLACES.
WE THINK WE CAN HAVE A
SHORT-TERM SOLUTION TO ALLOW
INGRESS AND EGRESS.
ALSO THE SITUATION, BECAUSE THE
BRIDGE WAS SEVERED, THE LOCAL
UTILITY HAS NOT HAD ANYBODY
LOOKING AT THE POWER SITUATION.
WHAT I SAID IS WE'RE GOING TO
PROVIDE CHINOOK HELICOPTERS FROM
THE NATIONAL GUARD TO BRING
LINEMEN ON TO SANIBEL ISLAND TO
INSPECT THE SUBSTATIONS, SEE
WHAT'S DAMAGED, AND START TO
PREPARE IT.
I THINK YOU JUST NEED TO GET
PEOPLE ON THERE, AN THEY NEED TO
START DOING WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE, CLEARING ROADS.
WE ARE WORKING ON THE ROADS, AND
ALL THAT NOW, CLEARING THE
DEBRIS, GETTING THE ELECTRICAL
BACK UP.
SO YOU'RE GOING TO SOON SEE
LINEMEN BROUGHT IN BY HELICOPTER
TO PLACES LIKE SANIBEL AND PINE
ISLAND, BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
WAIT FOR THIS.
WE WANT TO DO AS MUCH AS WE CAN
NOW.
>> Sean: WHAT IS YOUR REACTION,
GOVERNOR, TO THE VICE PRESIDENT,
IT'S OUR LOWEST INCOME
COMMUNITIES, OUR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR, THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED BY
THESE EXTREME CONDITIONS.
WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS IN A WAY
THAT IS ABOUT GIVING RESOURCES
BASED ON EQUITY.
WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> I THINK SHE'S TRYING TO PLAY
IDENTITY POLITICS WITH A STORM,
A NATURAL DISASTER.
I THINK IT'S RIDICULOUS.
AND HONESTLY, WE HAD THE FEMA
ADMINISTRATOR IN FLORIDA WITH
US, AND SHE THREW COLD WATER ON
THAT.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
IT'S TOTALLY INAPPROPRIATE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO POLITICALIZE
EVERY TRAGEDY IN THIS COUNTRY.
PEOPLE ARE SICK OF THE NONSENSE.
THEY WANT PEOPLE HELPED,
EVERYONE BAND TOGETHER, AND GET
THE COMMUNITIES BACK ON THEIR
FEET.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING IN
FLORIDA.
SEAN, THE IMPACTS SPANNED ALL
DEMOGRAPHICS, ALL INCOME LEVELS.
SANIBEL HAS SOME WEALTHY PEOPLE.
THEY ALSO HAVE BLUE COLLAR
PEOPLE.
YOU HAVE OTHER COMMUNITIES,
DIFFERENT RACE, DIFFERENT
ETHNICITIES.
WHO CARES.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE CAN
GET ON THEIR FEET AND MOVING
FORWARD AGAIN.
>> Sean: AMERICA STEPS UP AND
HELP FOREIGN COUNTRIES.
WE STEP UP WHEN ANOTHER STATION
HAS A SITUATION LIKE THIS.
FLORIDA DESERVES THE EXACT SAME
TREATMENT.
YOU'RE RIGHT IN THE SENSE THAT
THIS IS A ONE IN A 500-YEAR
STORM.
I LOVE HOW PEOPLE TOOK OUT OF
CONTEXT -- I FELT THEY TOOK IT
OUT OF CONTEXT, YOUR REMARKS.
YOU KNOW, UNFORTUNATELY, THERE
ARE ALWAYS BAD PEOPLE THAT WILL
TRY TO CAPITALIZE ON A TRAGEDY.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT WOULD GO
OUT AND INVOLVE THEMSELVES IN
THINGS LIKE LOOTING.
YOU'RE SAYING, YOU BETTER BE
CAREFUL IN THIS STATE, BECAUSE
PEOPLE IN THIS STATE HAVE THEIR
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS TO
PROTECT THEIR HOMES AND FAMILY.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT WAS THE
MOST CONTROVERSIAL THING TO SAY.
IF ANYTHING, YOU'RE REMINDING
PEOPLE NOT TO TAKE -- NOT TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A SITUATION
LIKE THIS.
I THOUGHT THE COMMENTS WERE
PERFECTLY FINE.
WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> WELL, ALSO, SEAN, I TOURED
THURSDAY, AFTER THE -- THE
MORNING AFTER THE STORM, I WAS
IN PUNTA GORDA, IN CHARLOTTE
COUNTY.
THEY HAD ALL THEIR BUSINESSES
BOARDED UP DOWNTOWN.
A LOT OF THE PLACARDS I SAW, THE
WOOD, THEY SPRAY-PAINTED, YOU
LOOT, WE SHOOT, SENDING THE
MESSAGE THAT LAWLESSNESS WOULD
NOT BE TOLERATED.
WHEN THESE SITUATIONS HAPPEN, IT
DESCENDS INTO LAWLESSNESS, LIKE
IT HAS AFTER SOME OTHER
DISASTERS WE'VE SEEN IN AMERICA
AND OTHER COUNTRIES, THE WHOLE
SOCIAL FABRIC STARTS TO DECAY.
WE HAVE TO DRAW A CLEAR LINE IN
THE SAND AT THE BEGINNING.
IRNOT GOING TO CAPITALIZE OFF
PEOPLE'S SUFFERING, RANSACK OR
LOOT.
THEY'VE CAUGHT SOME LOOTERS, BUT
FORTUNATELY SINCE WE'VE BEEN SO
STRONG ON IT YOU HAVEN'T SEEN IT
LIKE THE AFTERMATH OF OTHER
NATURAL DISASTERS.
WE'RE PROUDLY A LAW AND ORDER
STATE, PROUDLY A STATE THAT LETS
INDIVIDUAL FLORIDIANS DEFEND
THEMSELVES, THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR HOMES.
>> Sean: YEAH.
NOW FOR PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
HELP, IT'S AT THE BOTTOM OF YOUR
SCREEN,
FLORIDADISASTERFUND.ORG.
I KNOW YOU'VE HAD A BUSY, YOU
KNOW, WEEK THE LAST WEEK,
GOVERNOR.
OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE
WITH OUR FRIENDS IN THE FREE
STATE OF FLORIDA.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
I KNOW AMERICANS WILL BE THE